Oh United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
my name is Robert Roundtree and I teach
seventh grade science and Pittsburgh New
York which is upstate New York and we
focus on chemistry so I love to tell the
kids that I love chemistry because I
love the periodic table get in fact I
remember my middle school teachers and I
remember the demonstrations so when I
started teaching I kind of used that as
a guide that I would try to make sure
that I would give the kids as many
demonstrations as possible
now I don't think the sinks is the least
bit boring I think more times than that
I use it as what's called a motivator
meaning you try to do something the
research says the kids will remember
whatever you say first and whatever you
say last and if you're lucky and they'll
remember something in between and that's
always the trick of putting a lesson
together but if you can grab their
attention at the beginning then you tend
to have it for the whole rest of the
class
you know the idea having a video for
each element you know his broke it
really is because that way in one place
you can go to and find out what it is
you want to know about that element and
then each video obviously leads to more
and more questions soon as a kid I don't
you know as soon as a kid mentions an
element hi Mitchell it'll be like go to
the video
metal-poor than what everybody started
shouting and screaming with laughter and
he never really managed to keep control
of the class after that at all so good
chemistry Mel Torme
you know what Brady said he was coming I
said well what can I do when I was
thinking you know and I don't know
whether I just seen the zinc video or I
went home and so does it fail but I just
thought that would be a really cool
demonstration that you know because
there's the you a factor in the YouTube
is it YouTube friendly I decided in
putting this together that I better find
out what it was legal or not otherwise I
was going to have to do something with
dry ice which would have been awesome
but not the quiet hoo-ha fact I was
looking for and I called the USA Mint
and I got the person who sells coins and
she thought was an awesome question and
she said well let me give you some
numbers and there's an educational
exemption that if you were melting
pennies for educational purposes that
that in fact is okay that is lead
there's white hot hotter than red hunt
hi professor my question is is it
aluminum or aluminium what's your
favorite element what's your least
favorite element hi uh what's the most
dangerous element what first got you
interested in science
so I just press space or do I have to
have the thing on the bench contestants
laughing
hey professor have you ever played with
Mercury
you